what are the underlying anxieties behind
cancer i mean they're manifold but i
think that we can identify
a few of them you know
it occurs to me that there's quite a lot
of anxiety that's uh economic driven
and i think that you know han arendt was
the one that said there's nothing
for like the promotion of of of people
in junior positions like a purge
and so i think that a lot of the kind of
cancellation or the urge to
to to punish or to um to scapegoat or to
rid
um people from institutions is driven by
labor scarcity absolutely um if if we
were in a more
abundant time where um elite knowledge
positions were were were not so scarce
then i think that there would be less
of a punitive impulse to to strip people
of their employment
but i also think that you know um
there's quite
a lot of uh anxiety in in
in wanting to to feel that your life
is um is is is an alliance with
certain um important struggles we no
longer have there's a dearth of meaning
as we've been saying
and so i think that people um attach
themselves to kind of manichaean views
of culture and try to be on the right
side of history as we now say
kind of glibly so you know it's manifold
but you know it also there's a
technological component that can't be
ignored we live
in a kind of constant panopticon we're
all always uploading
so many aspects of our personal
professional lives and we're all
critiquing each other in ourselves
constantly so nothing actually is done
in the dark anymore things that used to
they would have been scandalous within
your office now go global
if you look at jeffrey tubin from the
new yorker for example you know but that
would have been something that would
have been a legendary in the offices of
the new yorker
if it happened in the 80s and no one
outside of
that would ever really know but when he
did it i was having
some friends over for dinner in paris
and every single person that came over
american or french
mentioned it upon arrival i mean nothing
that you do
is not noticed now that's anxiety and
inducing too we're always performing
we're always being critiqued
well his was a special performance this
was a special performance
but you know it's all a matter of degree
you